snaking through the streets of the
capital tens of thousands of public
sector workers tried to drown out the
Chancellor's words
[Applause]
a chance may differ but the message is
the same more pay and better conditions
for teachers tube drivers civil servants
and Junior doctors despite this turnout
though they still don't feel heard you
just have to step foot into a school to
notice that it's at its knees and so we
need better pay
without my husband I wouldn't be able to
afford to live by myself
as the chancellor addresses the commons
tens of thousands address him their
campaigns so far culminating in the
biggest state of industrial action yet
the Sea of solidarity filled Trafalgar
Square and featured old and new faces
with far from New problems when I'm
talking about resources I don't mean
like rubs and rulers because we're kind
of used to not having those things
anyway but it's more about having like
the right support staff for students
frustrations shared across the country
including in Salford where union members
echoed the Rumblings that have built up
for months timing it on budget day was
no coincidence the chancellor reaffirmed
his promise to invest 2 billion pounds
in the nation's schools but his
ambiguity over how it'll be spent and
how these disputes will be resolved if
negotiations aren't happening these
national days of industrial action won't
be a one-off ashnaharanag Sky News in
central London